hi imax fans i'm andrew stanton director  of the new 3d action adventure john  carter and i'm here to show you all an  early glimpse of the newest trailer and  i think you guys will really enjoy it so  make sure it experience the whole film  in the best way possible when it opens  in imax 3d on march ninth  let em be crushed  you killed him with one blow when I saw  you I believed it's something new can  come into this world you John Carter of  Earth yes ma'am  what happened in this place  a new power threatens to destroy our  city  the dog  you are ugly but you are beautiful you  will fight for us  get on  you  not cause this  very nice  we will end it  I was too late what I won't be again  you